in our Black History Month the Academy  of Motion Pictures in Arts and Science  has prepared this special presentation  let's take a look hello I'm Angela  Bassett the Academy of Motion Picture  Arts and Sciences has long acknowledged  people of color and tonight we honor  someone who has shattered barriers with  his groundbreaking performances whether  in serious dramas like enemy of the  state were in whimsical animated  productions like Shark Tale or as part  of an iconic musical duo when he was a  fresher talent this man has long been an  inspiration to his people you can call  it actor producer comedian musician but  recently call him  Jack Black  the Black History Month minute  I'm Angela Bassett